have a go Murr as my name is Pierre
today I have an explosion worthy update
[Music]
your [ __ ] light man I'm hosting the
Humble Bundle weekly sale and I'm doing
it together with you bros through the
charity campaign so you might ask what
is Dave well I'll tell you what it is
it's awesome that's it that's all you
got a tiny little poof my farts are
bigger than this basically means you can
pay whatever you want for awesome games
like waka Mele like Wacha male of course
you do or surgeon simulator 2013 or que
[ __ ] or quoi or or exactly also if you
decide to pay more than $6 you actually
get Gary small as well and if you're not
convinced now then we gotta throw in a
speed runner for you sorry my Billy
Macy's came in if you pay more than $10
you get probably archery which I play
this well anyone remember that game oh
god he's bald Oh God Oh bald people I'm
scarred for life
and finally if you pay more than 15 then
you get the state of decay which is
probably the best samba game ever it's a
fun zombie game all these games are
really really cool you can pay whatever
you want so definitely don't miss this
opportunity bros but wait there's more
why am I wearing this but we also have
an anonymous donator for our charity
campaign will match every donation above
150,000 above hitting our goal so
anything about 400,000 will be matched
by this donator so that's pretty amazing
and that gives us a chance to along with
this Humble Bundle really really make a
huge difference here and
make it a huge campaign so that would be
amazing thank you both so much for all
your generosity so far you are it's it's
insane I can't believe it
also we have part 2 of Mirror's Edge
exclusive series up on the website
pretty pirate net so go ahead and check
that out as well
that's all for me I hope you bros have a
great day a great weekend and a terrible
life just kidding but you will have a
great life if you get these games so
good that's all for me
final explosion lumpy bras say awesome